'
EPEODBO OF OKES NOT
LU P.
YOUISAN C L BN TETOTEK OONO
OU OUSN R NPA CEW-S
APN .
♪
SH ">>WA JGTINONRNOUAL"
UENTCOIN
:STRE AND IYAW NGINJOS IN
.
HEORAN R FHE T PSIDEYNCN I
2020, A ALSWITH
TH OER
DES SICIONEEISTH WUDINK CL
EDLE
THINAVG CRDEE MOIC PTY.
ORANCHOIOR F JS NGNI UISTH
G.RNMOIN
GUT: TNK Y H FOUORMEINAVG
:ST AFAR AS TIS DHEEC
O
E
MOCT ENTXALYID DNOOU Y KITW
MES WATIAVO  TLE
ESGUT:EF I LUSBET CAOFE  THE
PO
TIRILAZAT  TONHAUNFOUNRT
Y
THREENS R  TTOEAUNR OUCOYTR
ARAPT.
LIKE-S CCAN PABEUE USYO R
Y
DOPRUS JT UNENEST EDLTFIER
PONDCSTI A
EW NS.
IF L YOUOUK OOARGH, NDRIWENOT W
HAHE TSEIA MEDTUNS ITI
ONS
ATTHRE AMINF ILASI TNGENSONND A
POONZARITIFFN  IDIENERT
,
I AND T OUTHGHHEATTH T A WREAS
WAND--Y  AD N AEE -ELTO-  H
E G INTHMPERURE OF
OUR
TRCOUNYN DOW.
ATD ANTHYS  IWH IEF LT T
ICCRMOAT TAR PTYMEBEO CON AEDE
PEINDEANENNDT TSTD ARHE T
DRWFOAR, AR PTYICWHHL  WIL
BETT
FY UISNIOPG,IN PARULOV M
TOE HA CNGETH IVEENNCTIUROFS  O
POLECATIL TOERADS LLCT AUA
ONRESPDE O  TTHABASREONNG ALEMO
US A T NNDOT EXTMES
ONEI
IDERTH S
USBECAT RIE GH YW NOIFK  LOUOO
H
E NBEUMRSENND IEPNCE-
-
INTSNDPEENMBUT ONU
ER
STREGIEDEM D ARAOCTS
NDRE
ANBLPUICS AOST O T
O.
NOWE KWPOHA TT TINF  OSEWVI I
OFINGEN TT.LOG ST
HOPAHA WT BE ORTF RTG INPA O
MAA JOY PAR RTFLS WAINTOINAMG
U, PLATIARCUE Y RLTHATMODECR
A
Y?RT
ESGUT:N, M IEA N D IIDOTEE FL
PALYULICARMENF ILA ID,
PPOS
TEAU[LGH
IAS WOC D AEMR T RAFORS Y26EA
EREVIN SOU ICE CIS RLDEG
RO
.VOTE
GHT BURIWENOT W EERE A S
G A
UNDYSFLIOCTNAM YS STEWEERWHE
AR A NOT GE BLTOETINNY ATH
GDO
EI ONEN IDERTH S
INI THLEPEK OPINAT WCH ATHG IS
O
R CMEANTOATELE
HA TT.
OUIF YRE A ANAEA RSORSE BLPE
OO
U S AREINATCRCH HYOG URDEA
INGE, LIKS HY W IITUR O
LEEMS ERSEO SNR UBLSOEANA
ERE
TTILAVENEANO YOE? ELS
[L
TEGHR]
E TH ISWANERSOST HATHARE EHE T
IVCEINNT OF R SY
EMST.
ELECDTE RNTREEPSEYOIVATE DOU
POPUTILAONAS, ASUC MH E W
D
LIKEO PROTENETD E.RWHEIS
O WH A YDOOUTOWENSR
ANTHE OERSW THE T 10% T20O % O
THARSTMO PSATIN VWHEROTS
OWI
E  VLLOTEM AON DRAOCT OR
REBLIC IN ISURYO D
ICT.
80% ORIDIF STSCTRE ASEAF SE S.AT
I NSN CASEE EVEFROM TPL PHEEO
A
INLLG I TN,HE APPVAL TERA
RFOGR CONTIS ESNA IALONLYS
Y
28%.
PELE D'O'TWHOV LE GO IATS GIN
NO OONR G GOT IN.ON
BUTHT E RIOLEEECT FRAN TE
ALVIDIDURSEM MBE I
92S %.
OPPELEOIRE A G TNGOIN WIOLE ECT
V
O AERNDRVEIN AGAARIN,  P
THUSCAE  AEYREINAT CERHETOG  TE
BATHN  OEIER AID SE,N TNDHE
WHY  TENHEOGMECO TTHHEETR
EYCA
T'N'YTT GEANONNGHI D
WE A ARE U FLLEDT.BYP  IE.
AWE F ARELLTESTRURAD, AS TNDHI
HEIS TSTIG BGE.HI TNG
E  HWEAVOLENBE SLLA D BIF O
ODGOST  THAEN IISNTD DETOKOR
IWHENOTIST  NNEES DIGORTOD  W
.
WAI GE TNTO HETOT  T
EA RL
LEPROBT  TMSHA ATAI LKUTBO IN M
O
D, OKANT  THAIS NT JOTUS A
DE PATCRIC OBLROEMBLRER PUANIC
M.OBPRLE
ITSYS  IA DEEMSTWIROBL.
THATY S  IWHHAI DO  TTHAVLEE
E
ISWO
E. DRKON
HO:R S  AFA R TASHELRO PEMBL
ATTHEDXI ESTHELS EEW, HO
ULDOU YIFDE INT ATHY AT
W
DOESORHE T FRDWAAR PED RTYEM
YTT
ESGUT:PAN  IA E  LSTIFRAN
SIBUSSNE,ND AO A ILSAV H
BN
NTAN EEUPRREEN
HEOFE  TNG THIYOS UEA LRNT THA
PEPO RLEESIN TNDO ESNTCEIV
.[L
R]GHAUTE
OUIF YDEW RARHE TM ITH, AT
Y RANELLTHERWHE L  WEYIL.GOSGE
WHE E ERARLIE THPO
CATIL
NTINCEIGESIV R? NHTOW
IT GS  ITO A OETUTE  MNDAK
,
VERY IICOLDEOG OALR IATLANFMMYOR
ARTHNTMES ATOM SLEPEE OP
.
THE PEOATE PLTHTHOV LE EOS
NTGUARMESL  WILOUNDSE YEY MON
,I
E  VLLOTCKU YOBAN IGA AINN I
RYVE PVE, RYN TIARSAIEIMPRAR
S.
E  HWEAVIS DTOO E HA CNGETH
TEINNT -GECH- AN I THEVEENNCTI
N
EASTD OENLIF STERG INOV HEER
TTD ANGENEG INMO OFRY OMRVE
WEREHE, YOAN WT ISTOU  LNTEO T
AL UOFS,AYND A MKNYO, U ,OW I
WEERO  T GALRELYFAO R,
E
E THER EVEA WATOY  WREHE
URYOIN F ICIANALVEENNCTIARE
HO TEDO ARYOW U OIE D
NG
VELARETIO  TTIE THEN
RE
PUPO.TILAON
THS OU SNDRARYVE D
TIMAC.
ITBUT TIS  IENCHLYRE AE.VAIEBL
E TH GY WAWEET IHE TREBYS
GTTGEINID ROSF  OCL-PAR
IEIMPRARS
.
THE LEATSTE L.VEINRMED ATT A
TOIFSHT  OIMN PEPRANIEARS
ANYO CANTIE ICVOOT VE.NS.ADDRA
IHI TT  TNKHAY VISER
STRWHTIGFOD.AR
ENTHOU NPRD EEA SOESOCS  Y
T'N'NYVEHA APO S
ERILS.OO
IFHE TE  WREEROTWRAEM DOCTS A
N
E RCAUBEPLI R TN,HECAUBEPLI
NO
N'E'MAAUT TOY CATILLN.WI
IMYOU T EMPLENESPRA OCEWHS ER
VORSAN CAK MEHE TIC CIRHO
O
ETHER SS  INO EILPOER
ECFF.
YIFOUO DSE THEHIWO T TLLS,NG A
OFN UD SDEROULAEG LISRSTO
BEULWOD EAMECO RENASOBL
OV
GHNIT.
WE CTH DANO  I VISIAIVTINIAT
ER
HENDOU TRYOU CNT
OTCANNFOAI WT RECOR NG TSSO G
T
TOACS T , THGEERCAUSWE
TKNOWILTHA WR NEL VE
RKWO.
AU[L
TEGHR]
WHATDO WE GO IS EO  TTH
COITIEAROU TNDHERYOU CNT
THRE AP,ED F U IHI WCHS A
F
ANUS,  LSAD Y,'E'CHS ANGEHE T
PRS.ES
STHO:IVOU Y GANE  ENLEMP I
WRGINBO AUTHA TESPRT OCTOS
R NASETOSALI MKIKOURWSF O
.ASALKA
GUT: TS REHE IESTA ATHA T
S
ALADREYAD M CTHE IS ANGHAE,
IATSLA AA,SKHE W
ARELLH
KAALASE  HNSAVSAA YWH IN RTHO EI
RETIENESTASVERE A, W ANDTHA
EAISTH MNSOR FOREN SATWSUR MKO
S
SHHA TT EAN CRC EXERE ISHE
INT NDPEENNTDGJUMEAKND A T
E
R DNSISECIOEO  TTHENT EIR
ATEEAIN, STAVOFD  H GG INTO
THROHTI PARIMN SAPRWHIEARS EERO
LYON 10%20 TO EOOF%  PLLE PLWI
PAE.IPICAT
A LOOF PPLEOECH WATISG INTHT A
O MEHO N'ATWH IT'M INLKG ABO.
OUIF YRE AE N  ITHTYNOMIRIAR P
Y
3%IN 8EF  OTHISTRROTSIC ADUN
ETH C, NTOURYOWU YOKNONOU Y D''
HAAYNY A S
S ATTH IINMESOTH WTHG AT
CAN
GECHAN, ASK ANDLAALHAA S
AY
TMADESHING CHAEST, JUSEEC BAU
O
TF AL GKAASNSET TOTOGDR HEAN
THIDSA, BE IISS
ERTT.
:HOSTUEUR O GIL USTNT.0: 100
IFANOU Y WSKTOT  AUEIM H Q
S
ABET OUTH PHITYAR, , BOS OKDAN
HEOTRAT M(2RSTE, 8-) 02740180
REFOR ANBLPUIC
(28-) 02740080E  FREATMODECR
S.
U YOXTN CATES UT  A2028-02(2)
80748-03
DYOURN ISECIOTOEA L
TVEHE
CRDEMOICAT, AR PTYWHOOFUC MH
THAS WENNF ILU YD CEBYROU R
PRTHR E CYIDESENAYND A M
F
YONEW ?RK
ESGUT: IET M O L AOTERWOF NDLFU
OOPPELEMYN IGAM CPADE, NSMA
MESOFREE DP IPNDIESH
ANS D
ECCONN
ONTIS.
THG THE INEVBEI LI--E  I AND
K THINEOSTMO PTCE PLWATNGHI A
HOAGIL WL ERE-  -ARERTHE
GOPL PODEOVEINE  EIT PRYOLALIC
RTPAY.
TH NE ERISYPAO RTHAHA TT AS
LYNOMOPOODN  OGO
SSNE.
[LR]GHAUTE
VEI HATRAN MY USENEMDO
ONLARETIIPS,ND WFI DASIFLTCU
TON  EVEANGEY VORTE
RETISTGIRAEN GONIV AHA TT,
,
DI HA BDEN EEA  FCRMOAT AOR
.CADEDE
T BULIEL FT  R TKEHEHIHTIG T
O D IREWEF  A TOI GNG
PUL
COOUR TRUNYOG T
HEETR.
PEENLEOP ST TSEHAPL PEOOFE
ENFFDIERTIPOT LIIGL CAAL
ES
ARYONOE T MY EURNE
.
A AWERERI ALLME
NSCA.
WEE  LOVLLR OUFERI AOWME
NS.
NDFRIEFAANS D LYMI WTEL ILVOOR F
HEE THOTRE, SIDND AST WE LIL
O VEHA TMECO TR ETOGHEARTEAFRW
N
DHAD VETONEINR .THGEER
HO: YOU WN TERI IURYO
OO,
MOREHA T60N %ERF  OAMSAANICS
YO
IT PTHOLARALIC PREESTI AUT O
OFOU T.CH
E THURRUSTCTCE FALORSE  MAK
ITE
LYAR IBLOSMPSI
U C'A'WIT NES RACDOYO, U 'N'
HA FNGANINCIMETH, E LLA DIWI
AT. YCKOU
ANRTPAISWIS LLOUAY S YRE A
RIPOEMWEIR TNGHEON OPP
TSEN,
HWHICY  THEHALLWI CIZCTRAERASE
C TOA XI.RETHAT
WIOS LEEN FRIDS
FOP T O T IT HAITSSIMS POLEIB
STA A VTHBLIAE RTD IRPA
ATTHS IYOHA WT U, RI WTETD ANYE.
YO TCIDEDEHEGOO  A AADNDTA S
N
KETAOMT  IFR.HE TRE
GUT:ES ITEEDMMIALYAFHE TRE
-
GH[LAUR]TE
LKI TA AOWUTBO HT A7%S HI.5F O
ANERAMIC AWAS NTHI TRDTY PAR
,AN
THER IS-  - A% 57OFNSRIMECA
NTWARD T AHI, AR PTYERD ANTHISE
NOLIIM TE  P TKEHE.SERENT
CAESIDNDATIK LEYS M'F,EL IM
SY PPTOAYSE RAITED NS O
F
LLIODO ONSF FOARLLS MYR
ENESPRIDUNALTI RIAN, D  B
E
SPCAN K EATOPL PEOOF
ANY
Y.PART
T  TSOHA C TISHETALATYSOR FHAT
ISOP HE UL P AOPAR MT,EMOVEN
ARRWDTY PAR, TGIT HARE
ED
CRDEMOEGS,AT RDTEISRE
BLREPU AANICS,ND IDEEPNDENSNT
LCE ARWE JE OMTON.OI
WEAN TIN SCER T HAOUY UNCOTR
O
INWOT RKT RIG GHW.
IFREOU Y AINAT WCH ATHG IST
, HOMECH WORATGINAU BEC
YU
FEES AEL RILNSPOIB OY ITTO
CO ITRUNY, MALT SOT OSOF A YOU
INFEEL MSOG MENGGIISVI
ANS D
AIDESP
ASRE.ABONLE
LIREOS MT LEONASABCAME ARI
NO
OKD ULLOD P  UANBEE LIK TSHI
F NISOTNICTUNIOL. WNGEL
SIT I NCT FOTUN WNIIONGLEL
ECABEUST  IIG DISES FD NETOL.AI
OWU YOKN AT  IIS SAS NTY
TEM
WHENVERYEONCT ASIO RAT
L,
WE A ARELL GO NGOI TT SELO A
AP
LE SICCA
ENWHSKOU Y A,HY WW S  INOETH
ME FHI AOR TTY PRDARENOV MEM
O
EDUC SCE
IT IUSBES CAWEE E HAV
-HCORERDITH,IG L CALERLYILIV
WEAND A EE ND ONLUSOTIOIZARAT
IFLI MIL US ONOFPRCAS N
IDE
THIS SN,UTOLIOWEHE TN IL WL
L
MFEELCHH UCMURET BTE TBO AUT
E
FURETUF  OUNR OUCOY.TR
A VECLHIE FUT AOR FEURTYS  IISTH
MAKE CHE TSE YNGHAESOC AOUDVEATT
R?FO
ESGUT: THEBE NUMCHONR E EGEAN W
NEKEO  TMAWOHA TT LOD ULUN
CK
LEOUR ERS UA ACTY LLDO T
HO
T  TBSHAWE HE TH WILDOL
ISPEN IMARD S IEAN
NKRD
CECHOIG OT VIN TOUARND
HECO
TRUNY.
WESUIL WL ORPPTDI CANTHTEDAS
T
TEVOADCAHOOR F TSEHA CBUESNG,
EE ND FO  TBE OUSOCED
THNE
UP RMICONGESAC20 IN ,22 BAU
AE ERISF OT L OHAODGO T
N
ONBE D
:ST FMRO ALIASH
CO IN ,MBLUIA
MA
NDLA.
YOUPARU E IR FST WDRH ITAN
EWYA
.NG
ESGUT:NDHE T INTENEPDE
IN !
:HOSTA,LI ACIEAO  GAH
ERCALL:OO GINMOD RNRO PG,ED
D
MR. YISNGOU, T? I
MGOD OD, NIORNGA.ERAMIC
LI
ENST.
G YIFOUE  SETOMSE TOFHO FKSOL
ATTHBEAV HE TH IENN R E ERFO
NY YTHRSEA, OM BEYEC
VEEY
Y.BOSS
KNYOU  I WOWHO
EA MN.
ATWHYO DO K THU INTEOUABT
RM
MITS
DWOUL P YOUCOASLEE ONENMMT
TH
DANM  I AEP IANND, DEENNT I
FUORSUY PP
YOT U.
K THANU.YO
GUT:ESHA TNKALOU Y,
IAIC.
THATEA M W TNSHEO LDOR T.
WETEEE ND IT LRMIMONINS  C
.
A% 75OFNSRIMECA WGR AEEHIT
ATTH.
YOLDSHU OUT'N'NG GBEOIO T
GTSHWAIN TONOND SPEESHE T ROFT
IFURYO L
E.[L
R]GHAUTE
SITBEULHOD R  T AOUOFY.UT
TU YOGE TDONGHIS D, NEANN THE
MEU YOCOE. HOM
IF CT HAISMOOMN SNDSEEN AE W
OWKN W IT, CA'AVWET  H
M
TSLIMI
THARFOE RWY PAD RTIS T PROM
TSLIMI OERMEN MBOFS GR CONS.
THD HO SUL W ODOURD K ORANENTH
OMMECO HNOANE D TEE S D..C A
STH
TIR EIULESTEMA DONNATITI
.IF
OU AEE WHITHA TT
,
ARFORW.CARDPTY.OM
S IT I SMMCOON
SEEN.
ITS I A SNIGCO OF ONUPRRTI
T
THSOME OG INSO HIOBVUS
NAT
DBEENE.ON
STHO:M  FROLLPEHOWEIOUN JCT
N,E
.YOW RK
HEICER, O.LL
CAERLL:D  GOOG RNMOING RNMOIN
O
OTHF YOU APS PNDROIAO  TBR
MBLAHIOR F TINAMS AZGM  FORATTH
FU IISN SS BLLLO.OM
M'I'T.NOYO Y NRE A A GBEUMRS.UY
I NE AAM ONUOT-NE GUERMBS
ILE CALEFIND  BEOR AHIUTBO TY.
SL
EEVEHA BNGTAN KIHE TER P
.POLL
I OFOO UR AFIR VE
AY D.
S ATTH IOFLOA T E,EO PPL
TH
NDSAS.
CMYA TERIRIEN, ISWHD  F IINEMTH
E ALONDASI KE H.IM
UL RMYESTSER W O 8E,5%LEPEF OP
WE
IC NE.
ATWHO DHIOU Y TER ONKTHEEO PPL
TH
THATLL REA IMAY DE CVET RY
X
INAND INRETEST
NO WASTOEA MN  NE  MORTYAS
MTOE.
THAG EEYNGEDE, M THE CCKSNKHI I
AIVOS PITAU BE,ECIS ISET
USUNLUAN  IISTHGE WN
YOEVER A HNEASTEOM CPUHEINR  T
O
ETCK.
NOSOFO, R  TBOMEDYROCOO NF
NTTH
H WEMIT THE KINDS OF INE
HEON TCEUR SFA,OU Y SNO KW,TOR
VO POFROTICAVE QN,STUEIONGET GTI
OUIR TOFHE
IN S.
DOYOU T ILL TE. THEIM
I'MDMA AZET  ABIURYO ATILIES A
D
YONGSAU YIHA TT THEOL PICEMS I
OFID S O AESRECO OUTF
RON.
IEIT TSO INTTI TESESNYMO Y
Y
T ABOU PO WHIS UYILANGSOWND A H
OUGD AMYASAL ARE E TITXCED
E
T POINRE NOFO
RNTU.
:HOST EHAC,RI T V YNKOUCHY ERMU
U
T:ES W IT ANTOAK SPEATO  TTH
T
UOM CESY INP  M
OKBO.
AWENG BREEIULAN MIP
EDAT.
SOHAYO, U SE TVEHEICOL PIT
NTINCEHAESIV TDRART E OENIV TL
MA ULAPUTES TOUHRGH ATRMLAIS
FUG ISRAINESSSMEAGND A
EREVHIYTNG.
WEAV HGOALE L HEENTT TGEES MSA
L
R]GHAUTE
ENTHAVOU Y HMAE NYATANRGIZNSIO
--N-S CPA AEPCCT-ED - TDT HAEN
EIUP HNGTEGHNI
HE TIR
AMINFL ATIMAONAR PNDOLN.ATIZIO
YOU T HITL  NHEAI H TONHEDEA
OCATTH SDIL IAMEAURS  IPOGIN
N ELFU OOLE THWHG.THE IN
MCISOALS IAED IRRIB A FOR
ELAMBNC OONRAF TICO DALIS
.
NETYTIGAVINDUTIS MTRHS
EA SPR
S TIX MEUIREMO QN LYCK O
L
A.MEDI
HAIN TROENT VIHOENNMT YOARW E
U
GO BG INTOEE  ABLE COM
TO
ERTH?
LAIAGN,SPE OVC- T FANORSHI
.ASREON
SEI ENSLLOU Y AATRE A W
INCG
USBECAEOU YEE IOMAST  S
G
N OF ATETIANDO
IITSOFRE FE  O L AOTFHE T
SEMA
REETRK PURSSES AM
NGRISCBIAN, DOUE  WSH
BLE
GDOIN MREH UCMOOR F LOC
LIURJONAWH -SM- H,ICY  BY,E THWA
TONDTES CHE  BMUPOES LS L.TILICA
OUIF YYOIS MS AL LUROC,AP PER
THS''K. BITAC
0020AL LOCSAP PER HNEE AVGOUT O
USOF B
ESINS.
S IT IARI C.ME
NW HOCAAVOU Y HRIA E THNGVI
MODEIFACCRY HE TRENO IS NE O
NGVECORIINEW NS OUR WN?
THEE ERAR SVIE OMOBOBS OUPRMSLE
DRINBEG ENIV BYS THI HERYP
LIPICATAAR WSME  IMITHN E TDS
ANOF, S ITD  IINRESHDD
ANG Y
CECHAN OG BEF INLEAB TO CEOM
ERGETOTHAVND A HRATIAL
ERCONVS.TISAON
VE, SOLON.-S CPA
KETP, U UUT B IANERNDST
DWH
A YATOUIN SREAY
B AWEREANNGEI MEDULIPAT
THATS  IE ATWH WO VEHA TOPST
ERGETOTH
:STOU YTI MENACEDON F
OOEK
IFSPEC IALICLY BYON URK.OO
TH DMOE REAAT SS ETAOM CNYPA
S, T MORABVAE LUH  ELEAC
OH
IEMS.
BOFACE'O'S NWOETRKOR INCSRAPOTE
WEHEOTR .ITBSES
UY'ON D'ENT EVAV HEO  T
OBN
OKCEFABORTO  TPAIPATIN
E
ESHARVF NGTI O
TADA.
INEASTDVIF  OHANG TNGHI TSOS LD
S
,E  WEAR SEI BNGD TOHOSE
WIHE T TEA MNSACBUO Y OSSCE T
EVILDEY TARF  OOUIOEH BAVAND
IANAFINCLER INT ST ESTOPEHA
E ATWH WT. NDOEX
WHAT Y DIDOU TBONKHI AT TUTHA
STTEONY  CAPILOLIT H
FM
THATLEHI WST?OWBLER
GUT: W IIR EASNTYEL
RISUUNRPD SEBYRY EVEINTHG.
THPEARE E IKLEOP LHOMEE  W
KNS  THIISUFSTF  OOI GNG
N.
YOKNOWHE TPENL OY HOLEOP W
N'D' TKNT OWUFS HISTOIISF  G
NN
SHWA, GTINONTRC.D., Y.UL
YOU ULCOD L ME INUPTOS A
L,
AICERTYNL AREONNYE TOTELAD HE T
NDCHTE IANTRUSY DY  THE
ULWD
OSAY,.YEH AH
REEYTH AUSOT N JFATHT E
SF
THISEB FACKOOUROR F S
CEFAS OKBO IBLSSDIEMOUG INAB
TTH
EOS E.ECFFTS
WH
USCAEY  THEEARRI A T
IOLLN
ARDOLLHIRA FNC ANDHEY
AE
GONOT  SG INTOHEOTHO TS ELMSVE
H
.FOE OT
ITHISODA S PR TT UCOFHET FAC
THEAUR O LRS A DECESAD
THIBENDVE CHEUR
.
CADES.DE
NENO ON EA RSOYWHARHE TY
EDE
BEDECAS HENDHI T?UR CVE
E CABEUSAVEYTH HEEE B.CINN  D
.O
LOTOR O .NG
WE NOPD EEPEAT RLEOTGINN  IDAN
T,HE THAYON U PL PVEEO
WHO
HAGHMIT D  UVESEOKCEFABO
NALYVEMS THEWEVEELS E, LREIK
AHYE ITH, ISOBA S PRM.LE
STHO:S IHE TOR ARE FARRDWA P
TL
OAAPPRN  WCHHE COM TO
A?MEDI
NOONT LYOW HSEOU Y UUTT, I B
CHATS GETHD HO SULE? MBEAD
GUT:E W HPLE AVA  AFOATRM
D
DATAS,IG RHTHICHS OUR
AA
ETIS GNGTIOL SREAND D LDSO
R
HU ORENDDSIOBIF LLNSF  OS.LLDOAR
AR S YOUANINEEG HAOFY  T
TMO
Y?NE
YOKNOWHO INGSES EI I
T?
RK ZKERBD G ERANOKCEFABO
.
A  IITS RIMAHUN SSTSGH I.UE
IFATUR O DETISA  GOLNGTI S
D
SOL'DO, N'U T YOO NTWA TOPST
TH?AT
SHODUL BINPAE SSGAW LNDARS OU
OUTAN OWDA RIGNDS,HT A
FE
DEDECISH TO  WE ARITH ITA THEC
OPR G INFONR OUOWVE CON,ENNICE
THE W N KD EETOATW NOWHS I
INGOG ORE TN,HE TEE NDSOAN BE
INT NDPEENANARGUDIOR FTH US
T
IS T NOTH  THEECYMPCOANEL ITS
N
HEIFD  TMO IRES  BY NETOE
MAOU, DESHGE BLDE SOINTTG
F
THATON.EY
K THI INOSTHERE A
HTRASTIGD RWFOAR
LERUS.
STHO:NI DONEP IE,ND LDEENNTE.IN
CAERLL:EE I SIGHE T BEMRO PBL
N
TIELECSONS AHE T.ON MEY
E THER NISOAY WER L AOW
LAS
ONPERSOMAN C C
TEPE.
HAYOU BE TVEO LI M AIL,AIONRE
TIPRAC OLLCAY, AHAR VETOESCCS
MIF NSIO OS LLDOARN ETOVE. RUN
EEWE NO TOD  DITAYAW WH TTHA.
VIHA TNGHESTA STEEAV
WTIECON WSIEBTELLREHE AF OL
ETHNF IONMAORTIANHE T CSDADITE
HAVE, EDQUREIR OO  TBEN
THE
HEIN TMS FOR, AYKELI SATG INWH
EITHTIPOR SIE.S ONAR
TRIGH T NOWPL PHEEOALL EY
RECAN  OLYN32 IS
TNDV
MMCO, CIERALATD ANTHS IEHY W W
ARG TTGEINADCHSU B CDIDAS.
I N'D'THINKHIRDESAR PTI
WOD BEAN AN ERSW, AON IND D''
LIANHE T RDKE CICE .TIVONG
ATTH JDST USADSION CFU TONO T
LONODR, AWCE PUTRO,SSUT B
E
LDSHOUHAUS JT ,VEE, LIK
ACO
TIERNSVATY PVEARAN, D T
NA
RALIBELTY PARALAN, D OFL
TE
PSGROUND AAR PESTILD WOUTOAV HE
GONT IOFONO E  AHO TSEON BNDE
TH.LLBAOT
HO:HA T. YNKOU
GUT:ES I W ST ANTOOAKPE T T
HEO
OUT INABY MOT NEIT PINOLS.IC
S HE IT.RRCOEC
THAGAVE ERRECOE NGLIOSSNA
CAOWGNAI NOS CTSVE OR
1. 5
IOMILL
NASETEIGAM CPA M $N,10.LIILON
OPPE WLEHO AGG PRELUED IONT
EVGHHI-LWO NELETS.RK
YW HODONG COUHA?THE AT
ICPUBLCIIN FANNG OTIELF ECSON
ULWODTH BE LIDE EAUT SOLNDN,IO A
WHPO P IROTH ISES ATVE E
RYAE
ICERANET GS10 $CAYO0 U
NYTO AU E ONYO
NTWA.
IFOU YE  HAV,01000 P
PLEOE
THTOGEAT, ERTHON IS EONIL MLI
DOARS,LLND A ASUF  OA OUENDD Y
ARITMPCOETE.IV
GHRIITNOT W FFS  IDITOULICT ET G
ANYSO PERTON ON DECE,AT BSE
WHATS HATHOFIN KD ?ON MEY
IF YE  GOUAVOPLEEMOCCYRA
SLLDOAR ID WOT ULUG ABE H
P
UP.
BUT YHA DOUO DE LVEEA A WRSHO
OK S ANDHENDOU TBEAM SE
E
TH C AEYLLE FR THEE SAM
FIIALAC BD.ROKGUN
STHO:AS EOINTKENT
KYUC,
BLREPUINANIC L
, BERORT
LLHEO.
LLCAER I JT GOMMA T COTEN
R.THWI MAN YE.THG ER
WECO, LLA F LEUP OTSMMCOEN
THT FIE RSEON IS,HEREOS  ITO
MUPTOR CRU PN IOINS.ITOLIC
TH NE ERISSTINO VENSATIGIO
O
CORRTIUPONTHS ATHE TYIN BE ,TO
THBUT R OTE HET MMCOENGOI T
S
IDHIS EAN ORIRI PMA.ES
S TINHEONUAITTIHEIK LE
AS
TABOUHE TIRAN IN WHRE AA
EA
CRDEMOS GATET A -IVRRED
GE-T
CTSELE YEAAFTERR YEA,
HN
BOSOMEDY ON RCAUBEPLIORN
NDDEINPERTT ENPAY A HASRET BTE
OIDEA TWHF ATO DORU,
THN E
RNGOVEORNTME ME HYESONTL, DAN
BEGHMIT TOBL AE ET GEDLE ECTIF,
EYN UN R OEITHR, AR PTYETH
POSI PARTYROAN C CES LSSIN
TINMA PHERIRYETND A GIM H
MPLELY OTH OUTF ATSIE TUN.IO
DANT THACH IS  OGIANNG
ECELONTI PCEROSSHEOR F T,  BAD
Y
ONPI ONI
.TH
U.K ANYO
GU TOUNKHA YYOAN, D
ARE
T.RIGH
T RIGHEW NOTH DAR PTYTIIGESNA
S
DTORTG EVNGYTERHISEEC BAU
AOPPELEIN MREAKTESTG RACGI
CIDEBAONSIS OND SEUPHEOW H T
YAR
YOU HLOE AVA EOOFT  PEPL
NGOOCHSI WHI PARRU TTYO
R UNDEONSEBAD  PHI WCHTYAR I
SGO
HG INTOEMP ELTH
IN W.
ISICWHH  WHYNK T IHI
PE ON
PRS ARIMIEULWOD HECP,EL BSEAU
OUENTH Y SOU CLDAY WUT HAYO
THPEANK D HOLEOP WTOAN WT
SUTOR YAN -OU- DOYOD U 'N'
HATO  TPU D AR  ORT  NEX
TOYO
UR N HE AMTOCHE AVA OCEAN T
WI
TOUEHE T QABIOSTN TOU
TIRRCOUP, ONOFOU CERSPTOR CRUNIO
PA RISAMPO INTN .TILICS
WEPERE A SINNDGLI BIL
S ONF
ARDOLLUEINS FLTHINNCG EES
.OPPELE
TH G AEYLLTOO AS WN NGHITODAN
ACMECO BKOWOM SEHYEA RLL
[LAUTH
TEGHR]
U YOEARE, LIKAAI WT UT MIN
E,YO
AR SURALOTISY  NHIHA TT .GH
ISHOW  IHAYOT U EH SVEOME MOWAD
MIF NSIO OS?LLDOAR
ATTHS ISO RNEEAYOWHN Y UD NEE
TES,IM LIT S PTHO AT
PLEOE
OTCANND O  GANVEHORHE T
AD
CHENRIELHE TMS VS VEIN
IOAS
.WAYS
ITL S  IAL ACLA UBT TINS HIPO
.
ONSOMEWSSCE REO P, U DUYORU D
MH
OUTR CO UR VEIT
P?
S IT IUNFOUNRTEATIS IT
HAG,EN BAL WUTE  IKNL OW
TIS
:ST.HWA IN ONINSHGT TD., C.REHE
BAE ARDEERS TEOVEBHE T DL.LET VE
ERTHCUARE E ENT BATE
OR
INPASSPRTHG E T'IDESENA'S
.
S ATWH IRWE THFODAR PAYTYAR WF O
INDEAL TWIG THNDSEHE AIN COMUPG
AWITHIOOL SUTN FO  TGO
WAD
MTHATESAKHE TOFES BT
OT BH
S?IDEA
GUT:HE TRDOR FWA PTY
PR IPLCIES WMAN NYSAYREN O
ISLLFU DNAYPL IAS WN,NGHITO
ERE U HASE TVEHEIZOL PAR
EI
DS DEANOU YTWAV HE OENATS
WHOSSRE A ELYTIENALOLON CTRNGLI
TIE THENND AREGE
A IATS IOUN FCTNF  OOKW HOBR
P
YSHE T S.M TEIS
THE AL WE H ITTHD RWFOAR
Y
TISOAK ME BH SIRES DEMO
E
TOOMOM CPRBYINISG G AK MIN
IT
ATTHREOU Y ANSES RPOOLEIB T
VO ORSF PVE ERYALITOLIC PTYAR
OUENWH YRO  GFO REEN.CTLEIO
ENTH MAYEV WBEE  A GENET
FEW
LEPEOPEDLE ECT TOUHRGH T
HEFO
PAARRWD ATY RTTHSEEP RRE
SO RISEABLNAEE ID MDLNDATTH ETTH
UP BNGEI A
DGRIE.
ATWHFU IS  PY NNISTAPLEOE
O
ME TBO AUTD FHEOR -AR PTY
TE
ARFORWY.PAD RT
WE G AREO NGOI TPO SBEUP
ING
OPEN PESMARIRIIFBU, T INOU Y W
EV AEW F YAC RESOU
CAN
ALACTUA  DLYO T LOOFD GOO
BRIDNGGI SET TESOGR.HE
Y'DOU N'EDT NEO T WTH IINN
TENAXA EOULEMP YON DT''OEDNE TSE
RN WI50
ESAC.
IFEROU Y WE TN O ONER O
WO T
HAENTH TD COT ULBEAM A G
ANGETHFOR R REENE TIRYOU CNT
O
:STLD WOUOU YAS GO AR A
AGENSDA DUCE,ON SHEASH  TTKEICT
FI?STBUER
GUT: ID OO LKE
TINHE
TICONSTITUONND A IHE TRE
ETHER IINNOS THT ABG OUCALIPOTI
A
IERTS.
WEOTRE A NANIG B FOLOFS  P
L
IEPART
HOEYTH THEHTUG TD WOY ULOADLE T
FALIIOCTNASM AND PATAROLIZ
-
H,WHICY BAYHE T W WTH, EYEER
GHRIT.
WEHE TY HA TREO IT PVEOLALIC
S,RTPAIEWOHE TY VED ULHADAN WTE
MA MMA, NYHAEOR T
TWN O.
CUTHE SIENRRT N ATTUIO
SOG THMEINOFHT N AIGORREMA FUR O
NGUNFODIRSAT FHE
ENWHWRHE TY EOTTH UP TESEE NA
THOTID D NDENC ILU
BUFILIANERST, HAYOD U AS TVEO
H
:STNERO FM WSE JERET LY,YN,TE
ATMODECR.LIS NE
LLHE
D WOI ULOKELI TNO K MWHW ATPA
R.
YANG TABNKHAS TOU J THE
TOR NDERS IS D
NGOI?
ISO PERTHLLNAY  IK INHETHE
OFEMENY  AE  TRUBLPUICER S
,
I AND IO CAMURTO AUSS MRHA WT
A
NK TNGHI
ANTH
YOK U.
GUESEL WST FL,IR TLLE IMCA,ER
UYOLE CALEHOND  B TF ALOFTHA
QU, TIESONI ICWHH VE,  THE
WA
I TEPPSUORIEBED RNRSAN SDEN I
20THE MA P16RI.RY
ETMEGINIM HE N  OTHAITRLHE WIN
R N RAFOENESPRIDAWAT S
PR
EGILE.
EENWH H SMED AISONIINTHG
CEAB
AT OUMEME TNDO I, EL FT
RDTREXAOY ARINIL LOUPRD,
E I
BEHAD  BLEEDY  BLE UMYNCR O
AM AUGEVEEL BIEINR STHEE,ER BNI
BEEUSE ISOT C IRUORPT
E
T.LEAS
HE IA PSSE URME AGEENR,
UE
ICPUBLNTER SVA
HAS AN IS VIOE R FOTHY.UNCOTR
I WIREAGE H  MTHUC HOFISIO VIS
N
HED  ITIFIS GHE  LNGIKDMA
THTIUNL HEDAE Y IES.
HALO TVEO  A AVENDATREPPCI
ETH
.AT
STHO: V AOFWEIER WIOFF  TERTT
YASKSUE AOU QIOSTN,G,AY SIN
REABONLEPL PEORSUNE DENDTA
YOIT PUROS BN IOONG OMECIN
ANIN
PENDT.
HOPUVEWER INLLG VAWEROTS  TAYO A
NEOPRTPAY E S ENTHO ORDO T
ACU
LTF ONAER PSOTYLIN  IETH
ICPUREBLTY PANAR T AHE
WEY.TH
W HOURN CAYOIOEC DIS?HEN LP
ESGUT:HI T RISS  ANCTEAIOOU Y
LOT GEA  AFRT OMCUAR PTIRLAE SID
, S'T'LL IDEMO
ATCR.
EECH,RSU F  IYOTH ADONYGIN
NDDEINPETENIS IT  TOI GNG
T
CRDEMOS.AT
IFBUT OOOU Y LHEATK  T N,BEUMRS
THISE  AIG HRHEES DRE IRFO
Y
RTD-IRPAYDER  OINT NDPEEN
GAMON RCAUBEPLI T ANSNDRE I
DEONAMG S.CRMOAT
IFEROU Y WCTTOE  ALLY D
T
YOUT, M AOUREKEE ORLILYO TAV H
RSTERO FMRY EVEMELI AGN
R
EVEN FE M ROTHICPUREBLTY PANAR
THREOU Y ARAEM DOC.TS
EN IANREOR F P ADESINTAS
DEICCRMOATDI CAN42TEDA, YOF%  M
SUTEORRSN, THEN  IA DTIOCEMRA
G GOINPO STOUPRT TOC DHEEMR W
C
NENOMIT IFE  IOTREWE NE. M
IAVE RECORDPEF  OAPTOINALG
PEEV OLEF YERLIGNNT, DAN
CTSTRUALURLY Y M AOUREEOR LIKELY
TORA DNDINW  INTENEPDE
RES ICBLANEMANTH D.RAOCTS
HO: AS R FAASOU YRUN RHEOR F T
PRES, ENIDCYTE WHERO-EN  AOP
DAB
ATT OUWHT  THAD DITO Y
OUIN
LYRNTEAL
DCOULALOU Y TTTA K LILEIT B
THOUABT AT, ATTHT MP IAC? YONOU
GUT: C ILEALD R A TLIEATY
TH OOWN TEDEE BATA SD , GEANVSH
I
EDWANTY O  TSABO MINY OK- -
IICWHH,FOU YWOVE ER HAERND W
S IIK LUNTOE  ROR FDERE PSI,NTTT
THBADUI IS BECK,OO B TSEAU IKAL
ITOUABT T LETH.
HAYOU VEAK M YP EUONCER OUFA A
YOSHARU E  TTIOONG AADV S,NDOU Y
RRE ARSU BNDOUEDF STY AFEL ALTH
TIHO WERRE A FINRYGOU Y
RM
T EVENTO,VE ENT E ANDERRYVEWH
EO
OUGOU  YIVRE A GSPG INA CHEE
K. TORAL
MITSEESSIT W BYOH UR
INRA.
ES MITAKOU Y ISSO NTLEF O A
PRMNOAL TSOERN,T'H'SUFOS R .RE
IMEROV TAKITE  M YESOU LSES
ETPAEMTH.IC
TEAU[LGH
S GUI ESS ATTH IEON RWHSOEAN
Y
NEE LTED RM
ITIMS.
YIF I AOURE FTHN IST TOREX
F
NTATTEDN IOAN MTEYON IAN ARRSGE
--GEER DAN Y.OU
DI DIAV HER"PE OWVEFO" R
Y
LO.
[L
TEGHR]
WAS E CEERNTTEF  OAT
ION
AFOR CUAR PTIRIR LAPETI OODF ,ME
END ANEVWAHA TT ENOUO T
IN
E UEFLNCYE THWA Y INT
AT
WITHHE T.OR WLD
TAI LK ABO R TUTHE OLIEATY
INNNG P FORNTSIREDES, A LE,IKU
IITS A NOTVEACN TIRSEA LDEPHI
T KELI I BOUSHLD
K  TWEALOUABTEA L- RSDE 'DOI N'T
TTE SEGE FG ININF NTRO OA
TV
RACAMEND API ONGNIS  A O AANCT
E
IPERADSH
TH ISHE IPS SNGETOMHIOOU Y D
QUDY TLANER INTALRSPEOND, LYAN
YOE  CAROUABT TKS FHEOLNGOR WKI
ONHAR OUBE.LF
ATTHTS  INOT WHAICOL PITSLOS OK
LIODAYREAL.LY
ENTHONOU Y WYR DEWHE EO PPLEMSE
KE BSOROCOANN D
UPRRT.
R OUS OCPRESLYTUACALMAIL WL
KV
SO RENEA PBLNAEPLEOE LSES
RE OABONLER TI.
IN PPET,AR SES TNDIMPEIT WH LEOP
OWHED SCHEUL- -HO WULCH SED
E
VOLVERO AU.D UNYO
NCU YOFUNONTI OPP AE.RAEANC
PAEMCOY THBETIS MEOPRALON O
UN
FULPL.
SHADLEEROM BIPEC
TESHE
ARAPPEF CEAN OSHADLEER.IP
ESGUT:EA YH, W AHAE VE OUN BCH
E
HOLEOP WRE AER LITLYALT JUS
TRNG TOTI S LLAMUTEHIDEEARS
L
R]GHAUTE
USBECA ITHE ATWATHS E Y
OUR
PRISESOCS
IT IGRNOS T OUT,EA Y
NO KW?
KTHINUT ABOF LL A OETH
ENENPHOMAL P--PLEOE ND A Y
OUWA
THITCNGE S HIARLYOBPRAB
QU
IEIFD.
'GOINTOG  S SAYNGETOMHI
DR
ICAT.
WE HIFE  TREO LINUP AUN B
F
ANERAMICNYOFS  AROAC BKGEYD UNTH
WEOM CEO THSIDEE CIT TONHA
WOABPRD OB DLYOET BRTE TNHA
ECR OUELPRD TERETIENESTASVE
NGHRITU , OWYO
OWKN?
ITS  IT  PINARECABEUSN I O
EO
E EC BOMCT EANLE
TAESPRENOWVETI NEE ND TOAV H
N RTCEAIF NDKI OALRSPEONY.IT
WO MD ULBEREH UCMOY IK LEL
TOHA
A CTAININ KDTUF  ONALRA
OUCKBAGR.ND
AU[L
TEGHR]
AND ITIM  ANANLYVE ARO INT
D
GUY.
IAS WDY N AER KSI AANWI GIDRO
G
.
LALTE W IANO TOD  DADS WARE
BO
FOSO, CEOFR FIAS W A
ER VY
UAUNUSLNG THIINBU, T  A
AYI
NTWAEAO  TSPTHFOK R OVINE TRTS
AMGS UHO WCTUS SPE MHE TREHTIG
ET SBEOMNGHI WITNGRO W
THH E
FOLKWHO S  TDOHIR FOA LINIVG
AN
TSAD Y,IGREHE MHT B WWAE YS
NAT TREROHE T PSSCEYO SO
T
FFA DIKIENERT  ONDFE EO PPL
INH
EOO D A AR,NDU O LSYO NOT
VEHA 'PLEOE'RSS WOTENDCIES
ELVEEDAT O.TIR ME
HO:ET LS''ROARHE FM
OH J.
LLCA:ERD  GOOG,RNMOIN-S CPA
ORODGO MORNGNI MPENGNI, R.O,DR M
YA
I  TNTWAED YHEO AROUR OUTHTSGH
ONIN, OFEASTD INRE CATWA G NE
RTY -USBE- CASTYOE U NET ARA
A
YRT ANDOME OF
S THEEAM
-SUISES- K YOUVEW,NO EONRYE I
PTHWI ATYAR UILNTHE TIRARTY
IS SINGASTNGETOMHIHE T
YPE
LYONRSALOTRE A NANN  IGR
TSWI
D, THANTHHE TN  S AEYRECKTU
WITH P
TYAR.
EAINSTTAOFD  SA INRTG WNEAR P,TY
REATWH ATHOU YR GHOUTSAN ON
ALCEANF OESON CGRENSMHA T
AWILLEEGR TOBA DISND TTY PHEAR
SYEMLT ARETOGHE
, SOOWU YOKN,OU YAN BIALL AEGENC
EEBETWN INTUMNCBEON CANESGRSM
YOATTH, ,KNU OWNC O ATHE EY
REL
INTEECD E FF OICEYTHIL W
LAG
DE RETO TBAISNDTY PHEAR
SYNDEMST AUS JT H PE AVNO?TIARES
BETHUSCAE ETE SYSREWEM  AN I
NO
PL PW,EOJUE ST V AE OTUP
ND
WNDO LAR PTY
ESIN.
TH NE ERISONEA RSOEV IN
AICAMPONINGNG IEOL PICS, BEN
E
PEOP ARE TOI GNG OVOO TE
NPA
NEY RTLI
:ST ON. JK,OH.HO
INFASCARINATG .MEGUNTN
I
IKET.
T,FIRSHE FD
TY PAR''
INARALRVS  BVEE RY
ADRO.
ONE O ITHF EME GRS ACDAN
LETO INCRAE, AHETCS,WEINGA,
LOELUR O FERW LOAM
ANICS.
ATWHEE  WARPSETBOUT
S  A
EMSYSTISHA TT ULAN MIPINATG U
SN
INTUD RNGAUSG  AACSTIN E
HOT
R.
REWE AOT N TAKANG INST,S CEON
YOKELI, U KNOEN DW,OZOFS
.SUISES
WERE AG RY TINUS FTOOCN O THE
MAEMRO PBLH WH, IC
TISHE
CTSTRUSEE URIT.LF
AIFUN BCHERMEF MBOFS
SSNGCORETOER WE E  COMERGETOTH
ANLEAY S, S'T'DT GERI O
IIERTS, LOU WLDATE OVTHUT B
ON TOFHEEA R STILIES
IEEN
RNGOVESCEAN I TU T HAYOLYOBPRAB
NETEA LSTOM S OKIE NDFEA T
IFUSCAE  H YOUBOE AVA
OF
435 PANPLEOE E THD ERE ARNO O
R-
RE AOR NO DNIGAZERO GTS,UP I
ISLTFIIFCUERO  TOPE.AT
L YIFOUOUK OOAR THE W
LD,
HTHEYSTE AVSYSEMRE WHE
HE Y
OFVEN TEHAE  MORWOANTH T
PAS.IE
I'G'M G TOUGGE A TSTWOAS
BSUALPT OIMR UM NBETI POFAR.ES
K THINITOUABT
TWYOU EARE, LIKISHA WT
G
ON?
OUIF YATOO LK .KHE T UHA I.,T
I
VETI PAR.ES
YIFOU LK OOAT A LLA PCEEIK
, EDSWENITAS H.IG EHT
I'AND G'M G INTO S TGEUGSTTHA
OUATTH WLDSU BE  TRIPEORO
OR
ENCURREMSYT ST, B IAUECSE
D
OF T THEWOES SIDNGIN RGISTGA AIN
EA ATH OER TLLHEIM T
HE,E
DWOULA AV HE TSE OITCOF ALNSIO
IERWHE, WGR AEEH YOON TS,HI
T'L'WOS RKOG T IHEETR'ON D'T
REE THOU YISN  OTHI','
GINRKO  TWOTHIT WH HEE ESOTMGO
RE
LEOP.
EEWE NIEPAD RTRGTOS  O
IZANE
VIACTI
ESTI.
INI THNEYOK U E MEDOR TO.N HATW
S ATWH IEAE THIDERNUL MB
?
I N'D'.KNT OW
THI  SK INITBEULHOD DN  AOD
NU.ER
TEAU[LGH
YOUNO KPE HW,EL
MAD KE
RETIEBMOERAKS SI FREEAE.BL
LOI T  WVEHAUYORGRE A A
NGU.
IFRSEM MBEF OON CWEESGRS
O
LSAY,'E' THAS VEMERS,IM LITF I
EREYTH WTATOE  SAN UNDP
S,
, LOOKUOISTH DS LYPO IET NOTH
WAO,TOY  GWOHA TT
D ULBE
OMPHEN
ALEN.
:HOST OUR GANSTUE, DW DRE
--
EWANDR YITG,AN WH ULUNS TI
.AN YG IWH, ATURVES NT
FOR
ICAMER
T:ESEN VORRETU FCAME ARIS I
O
TRONPFI TLPT HAHETRAIYOUN
G
ENNEEPTRRESUR TEAT HACRS JTEOB
INARIEITS HENDOU TNT COU,RY
TY ANOFMHEN  IDWE THMIDT ESAN
SO
I D ARSTTEE NTVEURERR FOAMAIC
N
,2011FTER HADSUOM SE
ES
IN-  -SCCSUES AUG T IHO
HTAB
W T OUHORDHA IIS TMEBEO CO
ANENRENTPRR.EU
S IT IRDO TOHA
I T, UGHOHTD  NWEEEREMO
TREPS,NEREURE ND A WOREDNE M
F
INHE TM SLA PCEIK LESTRE OY
ANGHRMBIIN AAMNDMOAL BTI,RE
ID ANSO SPEUM ANT NR BEOF YRSEA
U
THINNNG AN OATRGN.ATIZIO
I'OUM PRAYTOD  ST  IWS HANO
EACROUD TETHOFNDSAS AROB JS NDOU
COTHE
TRUNY.
HOWAI S BYRENOD BAHE T OMAEN M
--DMMABA AATISINTRN.IO
ASIT WG UR DINIMATTH TIE
EDAVTRELHA TT ITORE GW ZEEA RLI
OUY ONECOMINS WABE
MESFANORBYD ATUT AOMD N IOAN
E
ATIMELINEDLI BIL
S ONOF
FAMANUGURCTIN JROS OBTHHUG
A
INCOMBOFIOATN LOBAZATI
D
MAAUTO
ONTI.
THATWH IS Y  MENAN
YOFOU
ABPROBLYE,ET M MI HE WN DCIDEDE
TO P FUNORNTSIREDE O
NUN
ERSABASICOM INCE I
NRE
ONSEO THNOTEE CHLGILOCA
DETIMAONF  OANERAMIC
OB .
LET BUI NEARDTHHA TT UGROHY M
TITIACVI AESTEN VORRETU F
AMERA ICOVNDIX S AF H AAL
SYEARUN NNGNI AITPRONOF
ZAGAORNIHAONTI THELPTRNAI
UNYOGPRNT EREEUENRS.
:HOSTS THIS  I, NIDAELATMODECR
I
.NE
:LLCAER HLO, N YO MHEU AR
O
:ST,  YESE U YOAR.ON
GUT:CAME ARI
AN C.
U ARON C
PA-SN.
ERCALL: YESIIE BEL H YVEOUEAV
A PLAORM, WND A IDE WASONNGRI
IFPLOU YR FOATRMNC ITHDELUS
EEP
IOINIMATN ODU E BTICAON
DECO?
OU IIF CT  JLDUSATY SATHY MON S
IV I-- LINE  A RAL CTYMUOMNI
.
I SON HADISIS H HRYTOTIDU ECA
N
WIE  FTHIVONARYES IVHE T CIL
R.WA
ONROTE HE, HI TNGIE  LIV AIN
CORARUL Y UNMMITSED ANI TA E LO
OF HNGHISE.ER
IFHE TRECHS  ISUNG T AHIS A
ATFIAFRMTIE IVAC FONOR T
HE
ALSO-CDLE DBLLOEPRA
E?
YOANTHK
ESGUT:RE THERE A MVESI
TIEQINUI IN R EDNATUCIO
SYAU BEMECSETH OF E W IAYT I
OUT ILARNDPE PROXEY RTTA
D
ZIP CASESOD, REOU Y A
DEBING
K THI INE ONOFHE TNDATRE A
BAESNC I WTHS AT
ARE E
OVEROKINLRUG RAOM CESNIMUTI
ANINEROPATAS IF,EA
RY,LLHE T
EOLYON PEPLF  ONRTCEAI
BASOUGRNDVERE A OGOMRCIN
S RIVAOULERUSTGG
TH IFAE CTRTPOS VEAMISY  RNTPA
URIN RAL CTIMUOMNIUN AESROD
E
COUNY, AND IFNEOM SEOS I
G EKSEINCA EANDUNDONTI ATH O
ERLATT- - LR, WSHOU
E
IDCONSTHINERG EME N  ITHMESA
GHLIT.
STHO:Y, TONENND IEPINNTDE L
TONE INYN COMEW XI
GO, OD.
INMORN
ERLL:MOOO GD
INRNG.
DON'TEA RLIY LLBERME EVTE
LIRE ITSS HELYAL TIOOL SUT
N.
SOTIONFOR ,METH IS
EDUNITOROR,  CONRAPOTISNI UD,TE
E WHERECABEUS I AM ANT GIA
S
PEINDE
ENNDT.
TWIEPAO RTSG CT AINOS OINPP
N
ACTO EH OERTH, IR OTN HE
R,
HTHEYENE AVBENGLA PYIL.S  UAL
GUT:D.GR AEE
:LLCAER' ISNT  TRU
THE AT
NDDEINPETSENMBUT ONUH  BEROTETH
ATMODECR R AICNDCAUBEPLI
NPA
IERTS?
T:GUESRU T
E.TH
TR IATS .UE
:LLCAERE  W NALRELYDEEGE TO
T E
ITOFD  CENIZS U OTENID,R
EMSUPRT COE URESSTJUICFO, R ME,
THTTOM CMIEDONRE TASND A
D URUSPEROUST CONNUTITIO
AND
INPLACITPRG OFHUVE OR .NIMATY
HO:HA TONS,NK T
T:ES 1 IRE% 00AGE TY.GU
T HAE
LDSHOUURVE ORTZECIN TINSTE UNI
SAD ANI  ITHY ATMYN  BK,OO I BUT
ALNK THIROHE T PPREMBLS
E
ZECITITE UNSNI AD,NDYO IF
VETO OCIURRTN ZENSTE UNI--D
ICWHH,E Y  BTHYWAULT  IWOBED
VEFI DRYIFN LTCU IRRR OUCUTEN
URRUSTCTETH --  M TATHEEYON
WONDD ULFI WTH OERSAYN, IVE E
NY
COHE TY T D ULNO IDOTIR D
ITAS CENS UENTENID
LEAB.
MOS Y NEHAENBEIN DOM
INATG
TIPOLICSECOR F D
ESAD.
ZECITITE UNSNIOTISD  NOLHA TT
A
DN,ISECIOO S WLDSHE OUE B
NGINTHKI OBO AUTNIRTVEUR
NGCIUD
ZETINS UTENID,  ST BUWE
T NOINK AT OBL PURROLLS EMWI
BEBYVEOLD T. I
ARYOU LECOE MPORLYTE CCTREHAT
NDDEINPETSEN OERNUUTMBRAEM DOC
N
BLRED PU
ANICS.
I THK INENPEDENDUL STSHO
T
THTOGE.ER
I INTHK REFM-MIEMEDND D
S
REAND ANBLPUICLDSHS OUET G
ERGETOTH
TH IS STY WHI THTEARD
EFO
PAARRWD Y.RT
IOP HWIYOE U  C ALLLLCKHE IT TOU
AT FPAWAORRDM Y.RTCONSD ANCOERID
MOHENGVI TRYOU CNTRDOR FWA
,LI
Y.RATELL
WENG BREEID.LA PYE
B AWERENGEIULAN MIPTOEDAT,
TOS''
INPOT.
STHO:OU YTI MENOUEDON Y OIDR EA
N
L ERIVSASIBACNC IE.OM
AASCE CONIT IPTS NGLA PYIUT O
DAN R,LIEATY PLATIARCU
Y RN
ESCITITAND A SS?TE
ALPEESCIMU SLYTIYMS LUPATSEN
INBEGEREL DIVAM TEDO S?ICERAN
ISA  IT T NCCOEPOUATTH CK WLDOR
NO
ESGUT:NE OE F  OTHRYVETES
GINTHGSNGRI ON W T GHNO
R
TRCOUNY ICHTHS E X D ILTA.EDCRIT
OUIF YATRE A WTHINCHG  Y AISND
O
T $ A030 CORCKHE FOU YRLD CHI
OR GILNDRACH K YD,OUREW NOPASNT
TGOT IGU-  -I ATS ESTH BOU WLD
O
S. KURID
R]GHAUTE
G YIFOU $ TOTHE0
CK CHEOU Y
EARIK L,  WE,OWIS IRE G.AT
UL SWEHO TKED EPRET HAFOR.VE
44ISONECOMT  JTSUS AGNSIED
LEIN SERAYHOWEG  SEPD ULKET I
R.REFOVE
ASIT HADE OPLEES LS H
,
ASIT HOT SOOL ESPPSULIIT,
SHAEOOT G PEPL IHER SITI
OE
CT ALELLUAY D N ARANENSPD
TWITHAMIRHE FINIEILS AYHE T W
TH WAN
SOOSHE T PEFIVITE ARCTFES E
RY, RYVE, LE CARERD ANEVNEYO
OWKN W HASD OO LKE D TATHEAAT
E YSSA W HOUSHLDCHE AVA XD ILTA
EDCR GITOIN ON TEFIDENI.LY
I AMHR TLEILDMYHA TT IGAM CPA
NI
TGHE HAVD LA PYE IROA LE
GMAU TTIENNGUG THEHOT THTHAF I
D  SWEEN SOPPELEEOMON MY TEYHE
WILLO INMESOTHTIPOG SIH WVEIT
ITAR PRLCUTILA TWIY THIRHE
ESMIFALIONRE A C.RNCEED
HOE  H:ERY. MISAR
RYMA KS  IINY,TUENCKLIEP RUBNCA
.LINE
CA:ERD  GOOG.RNMOIN
I DULTOIK LE WHNO KW ATR. M
HINGYA TS ABT THENCUE RR
T
THPAJOHA TT EEN BIDKIS  ITA
S
DOSO OWNF M ALCIISDANSMAR MXI
,N
IE LU OFIT CAP
ISALM.
K THANU.YO
ESGUT:L, WEL YHA TNK T FOUOR
HU
.TIESON
MYUT ON OKLO OSISTH IHA TTSHI
POLAONZARITIST QUEHEN,IO W
U
ANDN  THEENWH W TCOE MEETHO ES
ECONICOM CIORSVEAT INSTS I
SO
M,ALCIISALAP CITM,,LA CSH
CLLAH,AS C.SH
MEIN ACA WHAVEYS A SATM TETH
ISSON ME WYS AYWA TOOER GENSOU
PO CTOORS.TIRAON
WEE  HAVATRPCOORALSOE CINM,IS I
MACTES RPE
IFOM A CETNYPA GINS TOROUB,
GOTHE NTRNVEMEERS  ITHAITOE  B
H
. OEMUT
WEAW TRTT HACEWINLAIY L WTHAL
STOTETRE NLOHA TT NG AGO
GHRIWENOT W AV HE IINMYN  M
E
T WORSOF ALD WLLORS, WEREHE W
HALIOC SIA P FSMORLEROWFU
COIEANSAN -- D, BWATHY E
YAE
LRYOW, AX TESYOERWHE U
ANCOMPKES IELIN MA AZO
YIPG
TNEXTINNOO THAXING  T.ES
CI, SOSOISALMOR FEG MAOR CE,PS
DANF  IE U YOARWNDO,T  IESTMU B
SOYOINTHG
DIU D.
NVE THCOONSAERTI,ME TO TOHA, S
BEAKEDO FIREGU W OUT
E
LKE ARTAOUG INABWHANT D
GOSALRE AI BU, T NG GAMOIO T
TGGSUESHA TT TNVS HICOONSAERTI
PIS TT AROFIP MHEANN.ATULIO
THEAY W IAKAN C MUPYOE U
S
IN SBYAYGOO L O TK,HEEOERTH PEPL
SHE ARPUR,G INFOOU Y KORW,NO F
SOISALMWH OR
NOATT.
OUENTH YTOAV HE AC UNP
WK,E
REALLYAL TNGKIUT ABO
?I
OUVEGI YAMN  AEXE.PL
EOSTMO PTCE PLWAHINGHI TS
D
E AGREUGDR PARCERIS HITOE O ,
ANHOWED  ST D ULGEOWEMTH L.ER
KELI,S ICIT  ISOTOISALM AV H
EOR
RNGOE VENTMEIAEG NOTTE
PDRUGONCERIS F EH BAL
OFMI
OIOLLNSICAMF ERS?AN
STMOF LL A O THI HAVEG INTH
MEVEGORNNTEG N OIAOTTEOUR
OULFHA W BLDESI SENRIE BLDU
G
WOU D ULYOEND TRA ONNEMOY
DRPEFOS R
LEOP?
HAYOU DI TVEO ISINSTGUHWE BETEN
THELS GOATHEPE SGOFICIC SAL
UYO AAV HE,N  TNDHEBIESTHE
G
LAWHLSBE, H,IC IN MYIND,
S TIMEMENDLLWI EP UDI LEA
S
HEIN T DRO WNGONECIRTI
.HO
:STHE WOMITN  CESO T
PRALENIDTIICOL PIT IS,F YOU
ARAR IN SAONIZA E , YSTH
RT
STUL SEPHOO BED  T TANCHGE
HEPR
TIIDESENAL DATEBE CIOMIOMSS
N
IDCAY ND EE ATONUGNOHTA STE
S LLPAETHE MTOATLLTIMACA
WIN
ELTHE LTOECRAGEOL CLED HO SUL
U
CAMATOTICLY LLINED.
ESGUT:S THION IS E S TN IGOF
HU
ROLOPY,
LLEAY.
E THY OPDUOLSHAITAD ME YEA NRL
IM FIBSSLEON AORNY TELE SE
OUD
N FORS  LOTOF O AICFFES
OUR C, NTOURYDANTA CEROULYIN Y
CAPRROTHW T IDESENHETOIN T
MI
NOGHRIT THTHW E D SHREOLTOE MAK
ESA PRALENIDTIE EB DAT
1I%
INPOLLCH WG,HIS I
RDTREXAOARILH HIGTO,  T
SHI
RSPE'O'T.POS IN
WEULDTHAK ME ERCRE ITE MIAOR
REANTIISC DCH AE,VAIEBLO T
VE DFERENT PNTOIIEOFS  V
W.
R  YIFOUALGOS  IE HTOAV
DIENT INTSF OW VIE M
,
POPENMARI WOUHE BLDE
.
D  NWEEEN  OTOPE UITP,ND AS THI
LOT G INOULL SOFMANT PEROIS
F
MOSTIOGR EEGTH AUST  S TT  IIS
TIIDESENALEL LEVBU, TMY IN
VI ET  IIS EALQULYUSEGGRIOT A
EVY OTRHE L
ELEV.
GH[LAUR]TE
WEOIRE A DEV INGT REYWERHE
:HOST A FTHNOERUPLOOLW-RO FM A
EWVI A WERHO YS SKIFN  POULA
TU
PRFON R T?IDESEN
GUT: A ISEFOM CURYOND  T
O
OMAKETE SURYSM WK THE FO
RS
D TH ACTARN IOSTTS22N  I20
DWE'O' AHAT VEE  TNYIMTE WTOAS.
O
:ST DTSOCEMRA
IN LE.
ERCALL:ES,QU MY TIESON I
Y
DOEMHE T D CRAOCTSETIONNUTR TO
K  WTOOROETHWI JINAN MCHND A
NRSKYTEIN SAEMEN, WHT I
IS
OUOBVI STHS EYNNDTA I T O WHEAY
R
?REOGSS
ESDOT'N'THE TH14MEME ANDNTIV G
H
TEMHEPP OTYTUORNIPEO  TEX
OREMTH, HESK A TTOM  R TIGESN,
E
ACPLEM  THEOMTHWI SHONEEO W
CAOGT GEPRONSSRE D
E,CABEUSNOOU Y KIN SW,EEG A
TH AKI WREOR L FNGORTSBYOBIS
,
INWORKFOG R S EEOOMNEDE LSAN
ATHEY NREOT W FKIORNG
ORDTIRAC
Y CRMOAC THEEMOC
Y?PART
GUT:' 'M
WAOT N AAN OREF
ITABILTHFOY R  TEMOOM SAVOWEH H
H
EMEL EXPD.LE
E THCCLYON AILNTOUABY ITI
NW
SOF IT THAOTHE T V WS ERINTES
IARGVIINRIND A AOUNAZO W
DEDECIHA TT TE Y HEARNST NOFAF O
EITHR LHIDEEARSP.
I K TH IS TOINGOG AAK TE
LILE WLEHI
YDOROUGE BIGR PITNTOI,
S A
SIGNF O TCUIF DFIY,LTN  I
BOSOMEDYKE SPO TO  TMEER OHETHY
TEKYRSMASIN NE T ANDTHSEHE O
ER
PELE A NOTE N  ITHMESA
RTPAY.
GH[LAUR]TE
WSO IEAL ILSPMYFOK R NLFSE O
TH
I ULD O KELI TINE SETH
T
NEDOSHN  IWA.GTINON
PEI HOTHA
AT SENST KORYR
ENSI
NDMANE AANOE J MIN A ABL
O
NEUT OLIITHA WT  TOU WLDEAK
EMR FOTHO TE  COM T TTOHE
L.
STHO:M  FROA,ORFLIDENND IEPNTDE
NELI.
CAERLL:HA T F YNKOUIN TORAKMYG
LLCA.
IGFTLE-R,HTRO WHT-RNGIGI, N, MEA
I TAT WCHUB RHEEPCALINS S
REIID SAT IE, W
TCHHETH
MODEATCRSHEAY S TE, SIRID
IWA
HTC CWA, NNI HTC FOXI --
DOTW  KNOYBW HOANOWY ODKN
CH TATO NYSEOO A
REMO.SWH
REWE A R ALLWISEAID TA CTHER
IA
ESLU.
I'EA58M  Y. ORSLD
HE FMYATEDWOR RKHR TEE J
SO
PUT OD OTATHN E E.BL
E IF WINE ARGOTOG  BINHAE ND
G
NEYOPO  TPE N ALENDTI GOTET
H
GE TEMO T TOR WK,ODERO PVIOR F
EITHRAM F TIEILS,EST HADO'N'
SEEMMY IN  AOI PNTAS  VEUAALBL
THO.TOG  D
T BUMYD  MINFE DISIFHANTRE T
NYO
UR MD,IN JKET USLIY M
NE'HBIGORM'S NDDI IS EREN
Y
ANHUSBS'D'FE DISIFHANTRE T
NMI
.NE
EREVTHODYBY KSINFE DIF.NTRELY
EVVAODYBY IFESLU DLYREFENT
.
O IS?IG RHT
WO WHIS
NGRO?
DON'T ENEVW  KNO BO WHTO
E
WHENAT I WS  TCHHIONUFSTF HE T
BEWSNE, ONUSCAE  OSAE YSNE
G,THINEXHE T NP GRT OUYSSA
METHG DNTFEIFREY M
TEMPCOLEOS OLYPPE.IT
DETHE IT LBTIM,E  WINE ARGOTOG
O VEHA TDOUTT, I BS HO W I
G
O TO D?IT
FTHEYIKHTIG LDRCHE IL.EN
RI IITS USCUDILOWEBU, T TOEE ND
WO
WEOLEE ND IOFAD-SHLUD NEVA.ES
EDNE RO  TBEIBPOESNS O FLEOR
UW
ONACN TI
:ISHA TT INET BH ,AM TPA
FLA.ID
YOANTHK
T:ESET B YH,OU ARE 1%00
T RRCOECO ATTH NOWE ONKN
WT
ELTO BR VEIE OINTHK A,MONYRE
CABEE USWEN RE A ISTESTHE
E
RMINFOBUIOATN
LEBBS.
INI THANC-K SP
S  IA
TECOUNT EIRWGHTOT  THAON IITS
E
REHYONAS WK  T IALITOUABT O S
BLVOFARA
OV L.WOE RK.I
I VELOOB J
VELOE EO PPLVING PLA
O
RE WGOH'HE TY'REOI G
TNGO
RAINTEH  WCTITPEHEOTR NDLEOP A
DOET SOMHANGHI TRICOT NT
TES
MAAND EMS KETHUD PRONDY THE
CAGOANOM HE  LFED ELEYE IKTH
DIOM S FHIETNGMS TORHEANVEELS
D
EITHLYFAR MIHA TT IGOINTO
MHELPEOVONVE ERY BINE  A
TR
CTDIREN.IO
TOE M B THE PGEIGSTNONOHEMEWEN
BOUSHLDSEFOE CUOND  W IS,HY A
O
MEEW F A WCARINS?KIORNG
BOE THLAROR FTI PCEARONPACITI
RATES AT-DUL MTILOADECE .WS
K THI INOWU YOKN
HA TT.
WELL KATW NOTH
KE LHEOODROUNSAAND D Y, O
K,O
E DOW  WRET GEMOEEO PPL
WOG?IN
HOW CR WDOE ORTEEA M?JOE BS
ARERTHE ERDIE FFTENWEAY WS
COBOGOD  AUTT, IUT B' 'GGOM IN
TO TGEUGSTT HAIFE EO PPLVEHA
REMO MN EYON IEITHRKE POCY TT,HE
ARNG GOI TO  TGOLOTHO E LCA
RASTREAUNTHA OR WARDRE,TO SRE
THSTHA TT  GE ORISONGOI TE HIR
ANERRAXT PNSOR  OO.TW
S ATTH IINMESOTHTHG E GENEROVNM
A
VEDEN LI ON,RE WHEI IASF
SAHE GERNMTENOIAS W GNGO T
JEACRTE AS OBINTHNOERAY W
,MA
AYE,YB M NOT
AU[L
TEGHR]
AMI 00 1%IT W TYOH U,
UGHO.
NTI WADSY  MKIRKO  TWO
AR .
I'L'D BE TKEO I EVLIE ARRKWO H
.
O AWERESATHN E E. PMEAG
HO:WE V AIERTS WANOWO  TKN
YOUG TURHO AS HTONINLIBOSH
E
TOELECLRAOL COIGELE GA TNGO
POTER LAVOOR FDERE PSI.NT
ESGUT: TOUNKHA Y
NK THICOHI TS ERSAONS I
INMESOTH YTHG AT COUANNL O
Y
D FIEL A TINHET.TRBSAC
WHO DN  M IEA THA
OUIF Y W GE ERTO MINO TO
TA
D ANOMINAND Y,SAEY HDWO, UL
YOKELIO DEEASER YOU
IN
NCUEE?
OUOF CEYE RSTH SOU WLD
NA.
ER OINRDIMO  TELTHATINE
EEL
L TOECRAE LLCOEGU WOD NE
A MUP SERY,ORAJIT EENTI
L,
TAOF SDS TEAN RNTREEPSE,IVATES
AN I ONONEG GOS INIT DTOO
TASO, ABINLKG  AT OUITYUACTLL.
EN UPDI LEA I YNGOUN A
CTDIREERN IOWHMY IE,N  IIN MD,
DSP  URIRTFUHE D TNGHE
I.
ITHATITWHS Y D HO SULLYON
BE
EDTALK IBO AUTABTHN E .RASTCT
T'LEB'S NAG INSERSTO
RO FM
INWYOMMOANG D TOANNTA ABHE T T
ETHD ERIK LEDOES Y, 'N'
IE
NGHAVIINES LS E.UEFLNC
THEY N DIDT WOTANTA CERRE, INMO
POARTELAD  DS EATOE.INOMAT
IFEROU Y WTOE AV HAE
ENESPRIDLEALTI EIONHE W
T
POWAS LAPUR VOME,OT SIKNEEO L
EE
OULDEVEROOET S FINT  A
NU
EAL RAAR
WE GOU WLDAJTOO  MOR PIOULOPAT
A
ANETRKS DRY TT O  TGEIN TONV
NE YK,OR.A L.
T  TISHABLSIDERA
ENTHE HIRETI TME TNGO S NO
INMESOTHG WE SBEULHOD  OSI UNG
E
ON-OADN SSUN, LE,GA AU, INYO
EX O ACTLLTHF E PPLEOE A
NDRE
TAESPRENVETISF  OSSLE
TEPUPOLAD STOTETAS
HO SOT
THESSEEMLVEN  ITHT, FOO
HIH
ATHEY G NREOTO NGOI T.DO
ATTHERS  IWH IM. A
ULU YOCODK  TALITOUABT OUIF,  Y
WOULCOD UD ULYOO  D?IT
'ATTH'S GEV NERNG TN,AP HPEO S
UL SWEHOS FOD CU TONHETE SYSIN
WAWEHA TT IXAN C F
WI F TTHHEWAORRDTY PARONE
THGSTHE INT  THAESTA ATEVEL
OUE ERENUS OGHF OGET G T
R
ANWE CITAK ME N.AP HPE
IT H ALRAPDYEA HINNEPED T A
ONASLET E.STE AT
ITS INNTUR O ITOESERT
O.
ITHATE WHS ERN.ONIRMA
TH'A'SFOS CUN  OOLALRE S
IS
WTHATLPL ILHEOUUR O CIGRYNT R
O
:ST IEC BKYSA BAM -Y BE- CK
S
INCHAS MSA.ETUSTS
CALL: IYONO KW ARU E G
TG
HETO TF ND E OETH SO W,HO S'I'
GORYTOG  T QO  TBE
CKUI.
TAMI  AMPRURTUP SPOD , ERAN
EN WTOT HE T IDEEPNDENTY PNTARIE
I D FOOW H.IM
ATWH IAN W SD TETOI IAYS
AP TIAECTEHEAC FTHA T
MRT.
NGYA OS  IANR SIUTDE
OFWA
ONINSHGT
INK THIISHA TT RFON WDE.UL
S ATTH IATWH W.NEE ED
THE ERIS TY MOOANTHPLEOE
ATR
INTOE O ASDESI WN.NGHITO
BUST QMYUENIOS  I I A--ND
L
ITAKETFF O--IN-LE S, IHE WHEN
R N RAFOESIDT DIYOD UXP ETEC
DEE JOBIE TON  BETHNE WINR
D
LAKAMAS AR HRITH BTOE
VIEE
ENESPRID
ORID Y T NOUOTNK TT?
S WAITDYLR AEARE PTERMED?
TH
YOK U.
ESGUT:NK THAOU, D THKAN Y
O
KITHR E DS WNDOR
MTHEYLON EAA E.TOT  M
A AWERELLME A,CARINSE ARALL
PAO S NTWHNTWA B THERT ESFO
OU FS,ILAMIE TND A IHENKHI T
A
S REAON RESCEAN TP'TRO UM
'S
AGMESSAU BE,ECPL PSEEOE ARE
INSENS ITHG ATOTIST  NNGOR WKI
'IT'T S NOG.RKWOIN
HAI VE AERY ENFFDIERTEC RE,IP
DVEA RYNTFEIFRERIRE PSC
I.
GH[LAUR]TE
K THI INUL SWEHOANTRD Y DIX F
THEUT GHEOFS  TMYS STE THAIST
NGEABRKIBU, THA T. YNKOU
WE ARELL AME, CARINSUL SWEHO
BL AE TOHEEE S TNAOM CMO
.
THD DII ATK INTHNDOE J AAAM KAL
WE TOI GNG
WIO N?
YO, KNU OWENWHAS I WNGUN RNIS A
NENOA MINSAGE AITHE TM,F  IUYO
ERMEREMBHA TTE  TIMEREYTH W
EACD
TALTULYGH TES F JOROE
LAKAMA
TEAU[LGH
M'I'RET NOSULD W IOUV''DAL CLE
TEAFR TCAY HEBE N TMEHESINOMEEE
TH I THI TNKREY HEWE TOI GNG
E
RUATFE T?MP
GHTHI OUTTHHA TT EY GOU WLD
ETO
ES VREOTI, ID D
TOUTHGH TULT HAWOENHAD PPN I
RTPAEC BYOSEAU, , KNU OW
GHOUTT  THAETHOU CRYNTYO, TH
UGT
OWHE WASITN  WGLTR SUG
TITHE ME IHTHO TUGE EO PPLULD
BENGOO LKI DOR F ANTFEIFRE
AP
CHOA.
STHO:M  FRORNLICAFO,IA I
H
FRSAN SCANO,ENND IEPINNTDE L
A
ER: GRND OOMONDG,IN AW.RE
'SOEDXC EITREOU Y A
OI G
.THIS
AMI N A INDENDEAU BNTECM ISE A
ED TSOIRL F  OAL L TOFHES.IE
I'M IT ESOXCED TODO BE ISG INTH
.
T:GUES FOR
RDWA.
LLCA:ERAH
STHO:EAO  GAHLE CD,AL
ERLL: H IEAVO  NONESQUTII','
U
PY HSTAPANHA TT SEWDR I
RU AINNNG,M IND AAMN  OTE
.GU
T:ES IIL W ITAL KE
L  WILHAKETA T QAST  ANSTUEIO
OR.MEOMNT
FOD.AR
AWENG GREOIVEO  TMOOUHE T CRYNT
D.RWFOAR
A YIFOU ARENENND IEPHONTDE WS I
NDCKSI A OIR TEDTHF ENSON NSE
O
INE, ME ND A WLELLWI CANT I
.UP
UNE THFOATNGDI FOURSHE WLD B
EHO
D IFRRIET  WATHAPPS HAHAEDEN
UTOS.
IITG GOS INTOET G WNOSEOR,
TBD
ER,  LETS''BEIVOS PIT
FIXHI T D AS,NDITO ND A
WY
THATNIFI C TESHE.NTOURY
WEEARE A B PIFUTUL
PLEOE.
G YIFOUETOM SNDNEEO ILLIDIVUA
O
TOAL TK LOOU Y,
LYVE.
GH[LAUR]
OWU YOKNI HA WT
ANME?
ATWHHE TISEC HK NIAP HPE
TO
US?
IAV HEDTAE LK TOUSAN
D
SATHOU AS NDOFNSRIMECA OYEVF ER
BA AOUGRNDNDNV EONME --
RUL, SN,URUBBA CY -
WEAN- D
N GEALONTHTOG GE
LLTIAUFUEIFY  W AY UACTLLESE
OURSVES AN HASUMS.EI BNG
BUREWET  A SEI BNG
UETP.
WE ARET N  ISEBE TUPO CHT  AEA
R'OTHET'S
ATROS.
AVWE HURTOE  TROITN  A
UN
STHO: MG, YR.ANISHA WT
LEURASABT MO AUNOFCE SUCSS AS
FOTHE PAARRWD Y?RT
ESGUT:AR WE G GOE INTOSU MEA
BYESCCS OW H MATY ANST
WE
UNCAN CKLOM FRO TSEHETI PARNSA
Y IMPRAR.STSYEM
CAYOU  BHAN VEINLOALT VEIAITTI
N
P UO  TTE S24TA
WERE A G NOTO NGOI TNRU
HA T
BUNYMA, FUHOT PEYLLN  IOU2220 Y
ARINGOGO  TEE SETHRO PSSCE
.ANCHGE
IFLD WOUOUTOIK LE AK MET THA
HA,ENOI JTMEN  A
FOTYDPARAR
OM.C.
:HOST ARENDWG  YAN TISHED  HEA
H
ARFOE RWPART THERUT AHOF O
"FWAORRDO  G -ANTHKS-RDOR FWA
"
FANTHKSR  YOROUODMETI T.AY
ESGUT:OV I LINTAE LKTOG
ANERAMIC
BA MVEE .CK.HA
STHO:AR WE E:STOU YOLAN C FWLOLH
STE THTEOFONIMY RMHE T ASCOY RP
OFIN ENG
RSEE.
ATTH FS  IIT P OORUR
GRROAM
TODA
OTANRHETI EDION COUESOM Y